10dans de l'assemblée générale
excellence
je suis ici pour tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé
le monde doit réagir d'urgence
nous sommes au bord de l'abyme et nous
allons un reculant
jamais notre monde a été aussi menacée
ou plus divisés nous faisons face à la
plus grande avalanche de crise de notre
existence la pandémie de colis 19 à
amplifier des inégalités déjà flagrante
la crise climatique s'abat sur la
planète que l'afghanistan à l'utopie en
passant par le yémen et ailleurs les
bouleversements font échec à la paix un
embrasement de méfiance et de
désinformation polarise les gens et
paralysent des sociétés et droit humain
sont mises à mal la science est
vilipendé l aide économique destiné aux
plus vulnérables
à supposer que leur parviennent est
insuffisante et arrive trop tard la
solidarité a disparu au moment même où
nous en avons le plus besoin
une image résume peut-être ce que nous
vivons celle qui nous vient de certains
coins du monde ou l'envi des 25 contre
l'envoi des vaccins contre la copie 19
jeter à la poubelle
périnée est inutilisé d'un côté les
vaccins sont mises au point en un temps
record une victoire de la science et de
l'ingéniosité humaine et de l'autre ce
triomphe est réduit à néant par le
manque tragique de volonté politique
l'égoïsme et la méfiance
ici l'abandon ce là bas des étagères
vides
la plupart des habitants des pays riches
sont vaccinés plus de 90 pour cent des
africains attendent toujours leur
première dose nous sommes moralement
coupable de l'état du monde dans lequel
nous vivons la situation est indécente
nous avons réussi l'épreuve des sciences
mais nous avons zéro en déontologie
excellence la sonnette d'alarmé
climatique est également assourdissant
le récent rapport du groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat a sonné le tocsin pour l'humanité
nous voyons les signes avant coureurs
sur chaque continent et dans chaque
région tempe et une température
caniculaire perte de biodiversité
épouvantable pollution de l'air de l'eau
et des espaces naturels et à chaque
instant des catastrophes liées au climat
comme nous l'avons vu récemment
même la ville où nous sommes la capitale
financière du monde n'est pas à l'abri
les climatologues nous disent qu'il
n'est pas trop tard pour faire vivre
l'objectif de 1,5 degré fixés dans
l'accord de paris sur le climat mais ce
sursis sera bref nous devons réduire nos
émissions de 45% d'ici à 2030 pourtant
un récent rapport de l'onu a clairement
montré que compte tenu des engagements
nationaux en matière de climat d'ici à
2030 les émissions augmenteront de 16%
cela nous condamnerait à une situation
infernale où la température augmentera
d'au moins 2,7 degrés par rapport aux
niveaux pré industriels
une catastrophe
le cdo vient de signaler un déficit d'au
moins 20 milliards de dollars dans le
financement essentiel de l'action
climatique promis aux pays en
développement
nous sommes à quelques semaines de la
conférence des nations unies sur les
changements climatiques qui se tiendra à
glasgow mais nous sommes vous à des
années lumière de nos objectifs nous
devons nous y mettre sérieusement et
vite
excellences mesdames et messieurs les
représentants
l'acolyte 19 et la crise climatique ont
mis en évidence de profondes fragilité
dans nos sociétés et sur notre planète
pourtant c'est des filles formidables ne
suscite pas l'humilité mais l'arrogance
au lieu de suivre la voie de la
solidarité et nous sommes dans une
impasse qui mêle à la destruction dans
même temps une autre maladie se propage
aujourd'hui dans le monde le fléau de la
méfiance quand les gens voient les
promesses de progrès anéanti par les
réalités d'un quotidien éprouvant quand
ils voient leurs droits fondamentaux et
leurs libertés
ce train quand il voit autour de la
petite et la grande corruption quand ils
voient des milliardaires se balader dans
l'espace alors que des millions de
personnes sur terre enfin quand les
parents voient pour leurs enfants des
lendemains plus sombre encore que la
diversité à laquelle ils sont confrontés
aujourd'hui et quand les jeunes ne
voient pas de lendemain
les personnes pour lesquelles vous
ouvrons et que nous représentons
pourrait perdre la foi non seulement
dans leurs gouvernements et leurs
institutions mais aussi dans les valeurs
qui animent l'onu depuis plus de 75 ans
p droits humains dignité de toutes et
tous égalité justice solidarité
jamais auparavant les valeurs
fondamentales n'ont été aussi menacé la
rupture de la confiance entraîne la
rupture des valeurs à quoi bon des
promesses si les gens ne voient pas de
résultats dans leur vie quotidienne
quand le résultat n'est pas au rendez
vous place est faite à certaines des
pulsions les plus sinistres de
l'humanité cela alimente les solutions
faciles les pseudo-solutions et les
théories du complot cela attise les
griefs anciens
la suprématie culturel la domination
idéologique la misogynie violente la
mise en joue des personnes les plus
vulnérables notamment les réfugiés et
les migrants
excellences mesdames et messieurs les
représentants
l'heure de vérité a sonné le moment est
venu d'agir le moment est venu de
redonner confiance
et le moment est venu de raviver
l'espoir et de l'espoir j'en ai les
problèmes que nous avons créés sont des
problèmes que nous pouvons résoudre
l'humanité a montré que rien ne l'arrêté
conte tout le monde s'y mettait ensemble
c'est la raison d'être des nations unies
mais n'y allons pas par quatre chemins
le système multilatéral actuelle a ses
limites ses instruments et ses capacités
ne suffisent pas pour assurer
l'efficacité de la gouvernance des biens
publics mondiaux
ce système est trop axée sur le quart
court terme nous devons renforcer la
gouvernance mondiale nous devons nous
concentrer sur l'avenir nous devons
renouveler
au contrat social et nous devons adapter
l'onu à une nouvelle ère c'est pourquoi
j'ai présenté comme je lé fais mon
rapport sur notre programme commun ce
programme offre une analyse à 360° de
l'état de notre monde accompagné de 90
recommandations concrètes visant à
relever les défis d'aujourd'hui et à
renforcer le multilatéralisme de demain
notre programme commence appuyé sur la
charte des nations unies la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme le
programme de développement durable à
l'horizon 2030 et l'accord de paris sur
le climat il s'inscrit dans le droit fil
du mandat qui m'a été confié dans la
déclaration faite à l'occasion de la
célébration du 75e anniversaire de l'onu
intitulé chercher une voie vers un monde
meilleur mais pour atteindre cette ère
de promesses nous devons complet de
grands fossés excellence pour moi il y a
six grands fossés si grand canyon que
nous devons combler maintenant
premièrement nous devons combler le
fossé qui nous sépare de la paix pour
bien trop de personnes partout dans le
monde la paix la stabilité reste un rêve
lointain en afghanistan où nous devons
redonner de l'élan à l'aide humanitaire
et défendre les droits humains surtout
ceux des femmes et des filles en
ethiopie où nous demandons à toutes les
parties de cesser immédiatement les
hostilités de garantir l'accès
humanitaire et de créer les conditions
nécessaires à l'ouverture d'un dialogue
politique dirigée par les éthiopiennes
et des éthiopiens au myanmar on nous
réaffirmons notre soutien indéfectible
au peuple un peuple qui aspire à la
démocratie à la paix aux droits humains
et à l'état de droit et au sahel où nous
sommes engagés à mobiliser l'aide
internationale en faveur de la sécurité
et du développement et de la gouvernance
de la région
ailleurs encore que moi yémen en libye
et en syrie où nous devons sortir de
l'impasse et tout faire pour que la paix
soit instaurée en israël et en palestine
au exhortant les dirigeants à reprendre
un dialogue constructif et à reconnaître
que la solution des deux états est la
seule voie pouvant conduire à une paix
juste et globale en haïti et dans tant
d'autres pays laissés pour compte ou
nous sommes solidaires en accompagnant
chaque mesure prise pour sortir de la
crise
excellence nous assistons également à
une flambée des prises de pouvoir par là
or ce les coups d'état militaires
reprennent et cela tient en grande
partie à la désunion de la communauté
internationale les clivages géopolitique
sat la coopération internationale et
empêche le conseil de sécurité de
prendre les décisions qui s'imposent
un sentiment d'impunité s'installe
et pourtant il sera impossible de
relever les prodigieux défis de
l'économie et du développement tant que
les deux plus grandes économies du monde
seront aux antipodes l'une de l'autre
hélas je crains fort que notre monde ne
s'achemine vers deux ensembles de règles
économiques commerciales financières et
technologiques bien distincts deux
conceptions opposées du développement et
de l'intelligence artificielle et
finalement deux stratégie militaire et
géopolitique différentes
ce sont les ennuis assuré
bien moins prévisible est bien plus
dangereux que la guerre froide pour
redonner confiance et ravivé l'espoir
nous devons coopérer nous devons
dialoguer nous devons nous entendre nous
devons investir dans la prévention des
conflits et le maintien et la
consolidation de la paix nous devons
faire avancer le désarmement nucléaire
et l'action que nous menons ensemble
contre le terrorisme devons agir dans le
profond respect des droits humains et
nous devons nous munir d'un nouvel
agenda pour la paix excellence
deuxièmement deuxièmement nous devons
combler le fossé climatique et pour ce
faire il faut rétablir la confiance
entre nord et sud et pour commencer
faire tout ce que nous pouvons dès
maintenant pour assurer le succès de la
conférence de classe qu il faut que tous
les pays se montrent plus ambitieux dans
trois grands domaines d'action
l'atténuation le financement est
l'adaptation plus d'ambition en matière
d'atténuation
cela veut dire que les pays s'engagent à
atteindre la neutralité carbone d'ici le
milieu du siècle et à se fixer des
objectifs concrets de réduction des
émissions pour 2030
qui nous permet d'y parvenir et qui
s'appuie sur des mesures réalisables
dans l'immédiat en matière de
financement plus d'ambition cela veut
dire que les pays en développement
voient enfin la couleur des 100
milliards de dollars par an qui leur ont
été promis pour l'action climatique
autrement dit il faut mobiliser
pleinement les ressources des
institutions financières internationales
et du secteur privé et en matière
d'adaptation plus d'ambition cela veut
dire que les pays développés tiennent la
promesse qu'ils ont faite d'apporter un
soutien crédible aux pays en
développement afin de renforcer la
résilience et de sauver des vies et des
moyens de subsistance et cela veut dire
que 50% de tous les financements
climatiques fournis par les pays
développés et les banques multilatérales
de développement devraient être
consacrés à l'adaptation la banque
africaine de développement a montré la
voie en 2010 d'un fellah a loué la
moitié de ces financements climatiques à
l'adaptation certains pays donateurs ont
suivi son exemple et il faut que tous en
fasse autant le message que j'adresse à
chaque état membre est le suivant
n'attendez pas que d'autres fassent le
premier pas faites votre part partout
dans le monde nous constatons que la
société civile mené par les jeunes est
pleinement mobilisé pour faire face à la
crise climatique le secteur privé
s'engage de plus en plus il faut que les
gouvernements aussi mobilisent tous
leurs pouvoirs en matière de politique
financière pour faire la transition vers
l'économie verte
en imposant des émissions de carbone et
la pollution plutôt que le revenu des
ménages afin de faciliter le passage et
des emplois verts durable en arrêtant de
subventionner des combustibles fossiles
et en dégageant des ressources à
réinvestir dans la santé et l'éducation
les énergies renouvelables et système
alimentaire durable et la protection
sociale
en s'engageant à ne pas construire de
nouvelles centrales à charbon si toutes
celles qu'il est prévu d'ouvrir entre en
service non seulement nous dépasserons
nettement 1,5 degré mais nous serons
bien de dessus des 2 degrés
et les objectifs de paris partiront en
fumée nous sommes face à une urgence
planétaire mesdames et messieurs nous
avons besoin de coalition de solidarité
entre les pays qui sont encore fortement
tributaire du charbon et ceux qui ont
les moyens financiers et techniques de
financer leur transition
nous pouvons et nous devons agir
excellence troisièmement nous devons
combler le fossé entre riches et pauvres
dans les pays et d'un pays à l'autre et
pour commencer il faut mettre fin la
pandémie partout et pour tout le monde
nous avons besoin de toute urgence d'un
plan de l'accès nation mondiale
permettant de faire au moins doubler la
production est d'acheminer des vaccins à
70% de la population au premier semestre
2022 ce plan pourrait être exécutée par
une équipe spéciale d'urgence composé de
producteurs actuels et potentiels de
vaccins de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé de partenaires du dispositif
acceptera à l'accepter et des
institutions financières internationales
en collaboration avec des sociétés
pharmaceutiques
nous n'avons pas de temps à perdre le
relèvement asymétrique creuse les
inégalités et les pays riches pourrait
retrouver les taux de croissance d'avant
la pandémie d'ici la fin de l'année
tandis que les retombées de la crise
sanitaire pourrait se faire sentir
pendant des années sur les pays à faible
revenu est bien étonnant les économies
avancées investissent près de 28 % de
leur produit intérieur brut dans la
reprise économique
alors que pour les pays à revenu
intermédiaire ce chiffre tombe à 6,5
pour cent et à 1,8 pour cent pour les
pays les moins avancés un pourcentage
infime d'un montant très inférieur
en afrique subsaharienne le fonds
monétaire international prévoit que la
croissance économique cumulés par
habitant pour les cinq prochaines années
devrait être égal au quart de ce que les
dents des rares dans le reste du monde
de nombreux pays ont besoin qu'on leur
injecte d'urgence des liquidités et je
me réjouis que le fonds monétaire
international est émis 650 milliards de
dollars de droits de tirage spéciaux
mais
ces droits vont en grande partie aux
pays qui en ont le moins besoin
les économies avancées devraient
réaffecter l'excédent de leurs dts aux
pays qui en ont vraiment besoin
les droits de tirage spéciaux ne sont
pas la panacée mais ils permettent une
reprise et une croissance durable je
renouvelle ainsi mon appel en faveur
d'une réforme de l'architecturé de la
dette internationale
qui doit être plus équitable
initiative de suspension du service de
la dette doit être prolongé jusqu'en
2022 elle devrait être accessible à tous
les pays vulnérables et à tous les pays
à revenu intermédiaire très endettés qui
le demandent c'est ça la solidarité en
action les états ne devraient pas avoir
à choisir entre assurer le service de la
dette être service de la population
une véritable solidarité internationale
permettrait d'établir à l'échelle
nationale un nouveau contrat social
un contrat social prévoyant une
couverture sanitaire universelle et la
protection du revenu
d'offrir à toutes et à tous un logement
un travail décent et une éducation de
qualité pour toutes et tous et
d'éliminer la discrimination et la
violence contre les femmes et les filles
j'engage les pays à procéder à des
réformes fiscales et à mettre fin en
terme enfin en terme à la fraude fiscale
au blanchiment d'argent et au flux
financiers illicites et pour l'avenir
face aux grands risques mondiaux nous
devons nous doter d'un meilleur système
de prévention et de préparation
nous devons suivre les recommandations
du groupe indépendant sur la préparation
et la riposte à la pandémie et j'ai fait
de nombreuses autres propositions dans
notre programme commun parmi lesquels
une plate forme d'urgence et un
laboratoire pour l'avenir quatrièmement
nous devons combler le fossé entre les
gens
le convive 19 a mises à nu et exacerbé
la plus vieille injustices du monde le
déséquilibre de pouvoir entre les hommes
et les femmes
lorsque la pandémie a frappé les femmes
représentaient la majorité des
travailleurs de première ligne elles ont
été les premiers à perdre leur emploi et
les premiers à mettre leur carrière en
suspens pour s'occuper de leurs proches
les fermetures d'écoles ont touché des
filles de manière disproportionnée
freinant leur parcours et augmentons les
risques d'abus de violence et de
mariages d'enfants
combler le fossé entre les femmes et les
hommes n'est pas seulement une question
de justice pour les femmes et les filles
cela change la donne pour l'humanité
tout entière les sociétés plus
égalitaires sont aussi plus stable et
plus pacifique elles ont de meilleurs
systèmes de santé et les économies plus
dynamiques l'égalité des femmes est
essentiellement une question de pouvoir
si nous voulons résoudre les problèmes
les plus difficiles de notre époque nous
devons de toute urgence transformer
notre monde dominé par les hommes
échangent et l' équilibre de pouvoir
cela requiert plus de femmes dirigeantes
dans les parlements les cabinets
ministériels et les conseils
d'administration soient exige que les
femmes soient pleinement représentés
puissent apporter leur pleine
contribution partout
j'exhorte les gouvernements les
entreprises et les autres organisations
à prendre des mesures audacieuses y
compris des critères de référence et les
quotas pour établir la parité hommes
femmes à tous les niveaux de la
hiérarchie
à l'organisation des nations unies nous
avons atteint cela au sein de l'équipe
dirigeante et parmi les responsables de
bureaux de pays le continueront jusqu'à
ce que nous parvenions à la parité à
tous les niveaux et dans le même temps
nous devons nous opposer ou la
régressive qui institutionnalise la
discrimination de genre les droits des
femmes sont des droits humains les plans
de relance économique devrait accorder
une place centrale aux femmes notamment
par des investissements à grande échelle
dans l'économie des soins que nous
devons adopter un plan d'urgence pour
lutter contre la violence de genre dans
chaque pays pour atteindre les objectifs
de développement durable bâtir un monde
meilleur nous pouvons et nous devons
combler le fossé entre les femmes et les
hommes
mesdames et messieurs les représentants
cinquièmement pour redonner confiance et
ravivé l'espoir nous devons réduire la
fracture numérique
la moitié de l'humanité n'a pas accès à
l'internet
nous devons faire en sorte que tout le
monde soit connectés d'ici à 2030 telle
est la vision de mon plan d'action de
coopération numérique saisir les
promesses du numérique tout en se
prémunissant contre ces dangers
l'un des plus grands périls auxquels
nous sommes confrontés c'est le pouvoir
croissant
des plateformes numériques et
l'utilisation des données à des fins
néfastes
une vaste bibliothèque d'informations et
entendent être constituées sur chacun
d'entre nous et nous n'avons nous lui
avons même pas accès nous ne savons pas
comment ces informations ont été
recueillies par qui et dans quel but
mais nous savons que nos données sont
utilisées à des fins commerciales
pour augmenter encore les profits le
comportements et habitudes deviennent
des produits qui sont vendus comme des
contrats à terme nos données sont
également utilisés pour influencer nos
perceptions et nos opinions
les gouvernements et d'autres entités
peuvent les exploiter pour contrôler et
manipuler le comportement des citoyens
la fois aussi les droits ainsi les
droits humains des individus ou groupes
et sapant la démocratie ce n'est pas la
science fiction c'est notre réalité
d'aujourd'hui et cela exige un débat
sérieux
il en va de même pour d'autres dangers
de l'ère numérique je suis par exemple
certains que toute future confrontation
majeure et j'espère évidemment qu'une
telle confrontation n'aura jamais lieu
commencera à paris par une cyberattaque
massive
quel cadre juridique nous permettrait de
faire face à une telle situation
aujourd'hui des armes autonomes peuvent
prendre pour cible des personnes et les
tuer sans intervention humaine de telles
armes devraient être interdites mais il
n'y a pas de consensus sur la manière
d'un réglementer ces technologies afin
de rétablir la confiance et ravivé
l'espoir nous devons placer les droits
humains au coeur de nos efforts pour que
l'avenir numérique de tous soient sur
équitable et ouvert
excellents sièges inseps toulousaine
excellences mesdames et messieurs
sixièmement fin nous devons combler le
fossé entre les générations
les jeunes devront vivre avec des
conséquences de nos décisions bonnes et
mauvaises par ailleurs à la fin du
siècle il devrait y avoir dix neuf
milliards de personnes sur la planète
nous devons miser sur leurs talents
leurs idées et leur énergie
notre programme commun en propose qu'un
sommet sur les moyens de transformer
l'éducation soit organisée l'an prochain
pour faire face à la crise de
l'enseignement et offrir davantage de
possibilités aux 1 8 milliard de
personnes que compte la jeunesse
aujourd'hui
mais les jeunes ont besoin de plus
il faut les laisser s'asseoir à la table
de négociations et je compte nommer une
personne envoyée spéciale pour les
générations futures et créer un bureau
des nations unies pour la jeunesse des
contributions des jeunes seront
essentielles pour le sommet de l'avenir
proposer dans notre programme un peu
comment
des jeunes en effet en besoin d'un
projet porteur d'espoir pour l'avenir
des études récentes menées dans une
dizaine de pays ont montré que l'état de
notre planète plonger la plupart des
jeunes dans une angoisse et une détresse
profonde
environ 60% de votre futur électorat se
sent trahie par son gouvernement
aujourd'hui
nous devons prouver aux enfants et aux
jeunes que
malgré la gravité de la situation le
monde un projet pour combler les grands
fossés et que les gouvernements
s'engagent à le concrétiser nous devons
agir maintenant pour sauver l'humanité
et la planète
si la mobilisation réelle nous pourrons
tenir notre promesse d'un monde meilleur
d'amante plus pacifique et c'est là la
force motrice de notre programme commun
c'est le meilleur moyen pour un
gouvernement de défendre les intérêts de
ses propres citoyennes et citoyens il
s'agit de défendre notre avenir commun
l'interdépendance et l'essence du 20e
siècle c'est l'idée qui guident
l'organisation des nations unies l'heure
est venue d'agir c'est une ère de
transformation qui s'ouvre l'ère du
renouveau du multilatéralisme une aire
de possibles ensemble nous devons
redonner confiance aux deux vont raviver
l'espoir sans plus attendre merci
[Applaudissements]
et un sac à peine je remercie le
secrétaire général